[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سيئه
بعاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره تردنا من
واشنطن حيث ايجاز الخارجيه الامريكيه على
وقع كثير من المواقف والملفات منها الحرب
في اوكرانيا وايضا جاء فيه تعليق على
التطورات في تونس
وهذه الصور المباشره تردنا منهم كونج حيث
تواصل النيران التهام برج سكنيا كبير
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتل فلسطينيا
في قلقيليه واضراب في اريحا بعد اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال والاتحاد الاوروبي والامم
المتحده يناديان بتصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بشان محو حواره في نابلس
تطور غير مسبوق خارج ارض المعركه قبل ان
تؤكد استعاده السيطره على الوضع موسكو
تتهم مجموعه اوكرانيه باحتجاز
رهائن في مقاطعه روسيه في اي علاقه لها
وبعد انتهاء اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
العشرين دون توافق بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا
بلنكن لقاء مقتضب دون اختراقات
وعيد صدور تقرير للوكاله الدوليه عن كشف
جزيئيات يورانيوم بنسبه تخصيب تقارب 90%
يصل طهران غدا ايران تستبق الزياره بالنفي
وتقول ان نقاط الخلاف الوارده سويت في اخر
زياره للخبراء وفي ظله حديثا عن خلاف
اوروبي امريكي على الرد متحدث باسم
الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول للجزيره ان دول
الاتحاد مجمعه على ضروره مواصله مفاوضات
مع طهران
تونس مزيد من التصعيد عنوانه الاعتقالات
السلطات ترفض السماح لجبهه الخلاص تنظيم
احتجاجات الاحد بدعوى تامر على البلاد
والجبهات تقول ان الدعوه قائمه وبعد دعوه
اتحاد الشغل الى مسيره السبت بيان لسبعه
وعشرين حزبا ومنظمه مجتمع مدني يستنكر
استهداف السياسيين والنشاطاء واشنطن تقول
انها قلقه من اعتقالات بحق ناشطين بذريعه
تواصلهم مع السفاراتها هناك
في ليبيا وتمهيدا لاجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه المجلس الاعلى للدوله يوافق
على تعديل دستوري اقره مجلس النواب يحدد
شكل السلطه التشريعيه ويترك شروط الترشح
للرئاسه دون حسم طواشن تدعو الى طاعات
ايجابي مع مقترح المبعوث الاممي بشان
الانتخابات وتقول انه يوفر القاعده
القانونيه لها
[موسيقى]
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا في سلسله تقارير
مراسلين الخاصه بملف التوتر في شرق اسيا
[موسيقى]
في ظل الحرب المستعره في اوكرانيا التوتر
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه يتحول الى واجهه
لصراع دولي عابر للقارات وكوريا الجنوبيه
تبحث عن توازن صعب بين تحالفها العسكري مع
الولايات المتحده هو ارتباطها الاقتصادي
مع الصين
[موسيقى]
اذا قتلت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فتى
فلسطينيا فيما اصابت اخر بالرصاص الحي في
بلده عزون شرقيه مدينه قلقيليه بالضفه
الغربيه وقالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان
الفتى محمد سليم البالغ من العمر 15 عاما
استشهد جراء اصابته برصاصه في الظهر بينما
اصيب اخر بجروح وصفت بالحرجه وقال شهود
عيان ان مواجهات عنيفا دلعت مع قوات
الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها المدخل الشرقي
للبلده حيث اطلق جنود الاحتلال الرصاص
الحي على شبان وفتيا وعلى شبان وفديه في
البلده ما ادى الى استشهاد الفتى سليم
واصابه اخر
معنا من رام الله مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو
شماله سمير ماذا بشان اخر المعلومات حول
التطورات في عزون
يعني حسب ما اعلنت عنه وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه قبل لحظات بانه هناك شهيد فتى
هو محمد سليم البالغ من العمر 15 عاما
استشهد متاثرا بجروح اصيب بها قبل نحو
ساعه حيث تعرض لطلق ناري اخترق الظهر
وايضا كان هناك اصابه اخرى لطفل اخر في
بلده عزون في شرقيه مدينه خلقيده شمال
الضفه الغربيه خلال اقتحام جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي استخدم الرصاص الحي
واطلقه على بعض المتظاهرين والمحتاجين في
البلده وعاده ما تشهد هذه المنطقه
اقتحامات وايضا مواجهاتنا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كونها قريبه من الشارع
الالتفافي الواصل بين مدينه قلقيليه
ونابلس وهناك ايضا تمركز عاده ما تكون
قوات الاحلال احتلال تتمركز في تلك
المنطقه
وتندلع في ذلك المكان المواجهات مع الفتيه
والشب من داخل البلده المصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه اكدت بان هناك عصابه وصفت بيع
الخطيره الى جانب هذا الشهيد الذي اعلن
عنه قبل قليل وايضا هناك عمليات حزن وغضب
داخل المستشفى فور الاعلان عن استشهاد
الفتى محمد سليم وبذلك يرتفع ترتفع حصيله
الشهداء منذ بدايه هذا العام وفقا للمصادر
الطبيه الفلسطينيه اذا نحو 67 شهيدا برصاص
جيش الاحتلال والمستوطنين خلال هذه
الاعتداءات
المواجهات التي تدور بين الحين والاخر مع
قوات الاحتلال وايضا اعتداءات المستوطنين
على الفلسطينين بشكل عام فهمت اسباب هذا
الاقتحام للبلده
كما ذكرنا ال سي يعني هذا المكان وتحديدا
الموقع او المدخل الشرقي لمدينه لبلده
عزون هو يقع بالقرب من الشارع الالتفاء في
الرئيسه الذي يسلكه المستوطنون وايضا قوات
جيش الاحتلال وفي بعض الاحيان تكون هناك
عمليات مراقبه وايضا تمركز لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي هناك
تنشب وتندلع بعض المواجهات مع قوات
الاحتلال الذي دائما ما تكون في تلك
المنطقه ولكن عند اقتحام الجيش للملاحقه
المحتجين والمنتظرين تدخل القوات
الاسرائيليه الى داخل البلده وبالتالي
تندلع المواجهات وتستخدم فيها قوات
الاحتلال الرصاص الحي وايضا المعدني
المغلف بالمطاط وقنابل الغاز المسير
للدموع لتفريق المتظاهرين والمحتاجين من
الفتيه والشبان من داخل هذه البلده ولكن
في هذه المره الجيش الاسرائيلي استخدم
الرصاص بشكل مباشر على ما يبدو وفقا
للمصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه وطبيعه الاص
التي استهدفت الجزء العلوي من اجساد
المحتجين وبالتالي كان هناك استشهاد لهذا
الفتى محمد عندما اصيب برصاصه اخترقت
الظهر وبالتالي ربما تكون هذه عندما كانت
تلاحق القوات الايطاليه لهؤلاء الفتيه
والاطفال والشبان في البلده وايضا اصابه
اخر في الصدر وبالتالي هناك تركيز على
الجزء العلوي لجيش الاحتلال باطلاقه
الرصاص على الفلسطينيين وهذا ما يزيد من
عدد الشهداء والجرحى بالاصابات الخطيره
وربما هذه الاصابه الخطيره في غرفه
العمليات في هذه اللحظه ووضعه مستقر حتى
هذه اللحظه حيث انها قد وصفت بالحرجه جدا
من قبل المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه وتحديدا
من مستشفى قلقيليه الحكومي وهل الاقتحام
مستمر الان سمير هل هذه العمليه مستمره
هذه الاقتحامات عاده ما تكون بين كر وفر
تكون اقتحام جيش الاحتلال ويطلق الرصاص
ويتعامل مع يستخدم القوه مع المتظاهرين
والمحتاجين ومن ثم يعود الى المناطق الذي
يتمركز خلالها او فيها عند مدخل الشرقي
لمدينه البلده عزون وايضا هذه القوات عاده
ما تكون في تلك المنطقه وذلك لتامين عمليه
مرور وتنقل المستوطنين بين المستوطنات
المحيطه بمدينه قلقيليه
وتقوم بتامين وحمايه المستوطنين ولذلك
دائما الجيش الاسرائيلي يتذرع بان هناك
بعض الفتيه والشبان سيارات ومركبات
المستوطنين على هذا الشارع وبالتالي
يتضرعون بوجودهم في هذا الاماكن لتامين
هذه التنقلات للمستوطنين وبالتالي يتم
التعامل مع الفلسطينيين بهذه القوه
المفرطه وذلك يزيد من عدد الضحايا بين
الفلسطينيين والشهداء والجرحى في هذه
العمليات شكرا لك من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره سمير ابو شمالي
هذا وكانت شهدت مدينه اريحا اضرابا شاملا
حدادا على روح الشهيد محمود حمدان الذي
قتل برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر ياتي هذا بعد دعوات
من فصائل فلسطينيه عده الى اضراب شامل في
المدينه تمديدا بجرائم الاحتلال المستمره
بحق الفلسطينيين
وفي تعليق على تصريحات سابقه لوزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
التي دعا فيها لمحو بلده حواره قال
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ستيفان دو شاريك ان هذا الموقف استفزازي
وتحريضي وغير مقبول ويتعارض مع قرارات
المنظمه الدوليه
التصريح الذي ادنى به الوزير
استفزازيون وتحريضي وغير مقبول وصدور هذا
التصريح المسؤول حكومي هو امر غير مسؤول
كما انه يتعارض مع قرارات الامم المتحده
الامين العام يجدد مره اخرى دعوته جميع
الاطراف الى الامتناع عن الخطاب التحريضي
والاستفزازات لا سيما في ظل التوترات
الحاليه والعنف المتصاعد
وفي رد فعل اخر قال مكتب الاتحاد الاوروبي
في القدس ان دعوه سموتريتش لمحو حواره غير
مقبوله اضاف الاتحاد الاوروبي في تصريح
خاص للجزيره بان هذه التصريحات تحرض على
العنف العشوائي في وضع متوترا للغايه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه واصفا اياها بانها
تسير في الاتجاه المعاكس وغير مقبوله ولا
تطاق وعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلقه
البالغ ازاء تصاعد العنف وانه كان من
الضروري اتخاذ تدابير فوريه لخفض التصعيد
في بلده حواره كما دعا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى التنصل من هذه التصريحات
والعمل مع جميع الاطراف المعنيه لنزع فتيل
للتوتر
من رام الله ينضم الينا خلدون الشيخ
الباحث المختص بشان الاسرائيلي مرحبا بك
سيد خلدون اولا ما دلالات تكرار
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه واستمرارها واخرها
اليوم الان في بلده عزون في هذه الاثناء
[موسيقى]
عفوا اذا
السيد خلدون نعم تفضل
يعني ما يحدث هو اولا استمرار لاطلاق يد
قوات الاحتلال والمستوطنين لارتكاب ما
يريدون من جرائم بحق الفلسطينيين
ما حدث الان في قلقيليه او في عزون هو
يعني وزاره الصحه تقول ان الطفل المصاب
مصاب بالرصاص في ظهره انه ربما لم يكن في
المواجهه وربما قد يكون القى حجرا وحاول
الابتعاد لكن لم يتوان الجنود الاحتلال عن
اطلاق النار على ظهرهم يشعرون في ظل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده ربما في ظل
الحكومات السابقه لكن تحديدا في ظل هذه
الحكومه التي يسعد بعض وزرائها امثال
الى منح الجنود حصانه من المحاكمه وعناصر
الشرطه كذلك في حال اقدامهم على قتل
الفلسطينيين قبل قليل كانت هون يعني
تغريدات تنزل وزير الاسرائيلي اصدر اوامر
اعتقال اداري بحق بعض المستوطنين او ضد
بعض المستوطنين الذين شاركوا في الهجوم
على قريه او بلده حواره
بنجفير صار عائله انتقاده ومهاجمته
واعتبار ان هذا القرار هو قرار غير
ديمقراطي وطبعا هذا طريف ان يصدر الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيه من قبل بن جبير تحديدا لكن
هذا الجدل حتى انه ايضا دافع عن الجنود
الذين القوا قنابل الصوت وتسببوا باصابه
اسرائيليين يساريين من او ممن يرفضون ما
تسمى التعديلات القضائيه هذه الحكومه
قادمه ببرنامج عدواني على الفلسطينيين لا
حول ولا قوه له فيها هو خاضع لرغبات
وغيرهم من المتطرفين جدا ايضا في حزب
الليكود لانه بحاجه لهم كي يمرر القوانين
التي قد تكون محاكمته في هذا السياق كيف
وجدت رده الفعل الدوليه
لدعوه سموتريتش لمحوي حواره
يعني هي ربما لرفع العتب فقط لو حدث العكس
لو كانت هذه التصريحات صادره عن فلسطينيين
يطالبون بمحو
بلده او تل ابيب وغيرها او تصدر عن
مسؤولين فلسطينيين مثلا او مسؤولين عرب
لربما خرجت تهم عادات الساميه واتهم
الارهاب وغير لكن يعني التصريحات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه والامميه تاتي في
سياق رفع العتم ربما لم تترك اسرائيل
مجالا لهؤلاء بالتحديد بموقف ليس فقط عفوي
اولا وضع اشاره اعجاب على تغريده تطالب
بمحو
حوار عن وجه الارض ثم سئل في مقابله صحفيه
لاحقا عن هذا الموقف وقرر ما قيل وقال يجب
معه حوار عن وجه الارض لكن لا يجب ان يقوم
المستوطنون بذلك بل يجب ان تقوم دوله
اسرائيل بهذه المهمه هو اكد عن اكد موقفه
بضروره محو قريه فلسطينيه عن الوجود
وطالب ان تكون الدوله هي التي تقوم بهذه
المهمه هذا هو الفكر الذي يتبنونه في
الحكم
يعني رده الفعل الدوليه هذه سواء من
الولايات المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي من
الامم المتحده ما صداها في الداخل
الاسرائيلي المنقسم حاليا تجاه هذه
الحكومه
في حكومه نتنياهو لا يقلق اطمار من جبير
وبتشل بكل ردود الفعل
نتنياهو شخصيا وهو قد يكون الاقدر في قاده
اسرائيل تاريخيا بحكم 12 عاما من الانجاز
الاقتصادي والترويج اسرائيل والتطبيع
وغيره في المرحله الحاليه غير قادر على
الدفاع عن اسرائيل لانه منصع تماما لما
يريد هم لا يقلقون تماما بالمواقف الدوليه
يصدرون تصريحات ربما
لغيرهم كان اكثر ذكاء في التعامل معها حتى
نتنياهو قد يكون مؤمنا بها لكنه كان اكثر
ذكاء في طرح الروايه الاسرائيليه
من خلفيه صهيونيه دينيه يرون في فلسطين
كلها حقا لهم وفي الفلسطينيين مستعمرين
يجب التخلص منهم بكل الطرق ويدافع
بنك فير كان محامي الذين قتلوا عائله
دوابشي الطفل علي عندما كان عمره
شهرا ووالده ووالدته هو المحامي من قتل
عائش الرابي هو محامي من احرق كنيسه في
القدس هو محامي فتيه التلال التي تصنف
ربما منظمه ارهابيه وهو قادم من منظمه من
احضان منظمه كاخ المصنفه ارهابيه في
اسرائيل نفسها وفي الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي
الولايات المتحده هؤلاء لا يقلقهم رد
الفعل الدولي يهمهم تنفيذ برنامجهم
الاستيطان الاستعماري القادم من خلفيه
صهيونيه شكرا لك خلدون البرغوثي الباحث
المختص بالشان الاسرائيلي ضيفا من رام
الله شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث اعلن حاكم
مقاطعه الروسيه المتاخمه للحدود
الاوكرانيه مقتل شخصين في اطلاق نار
نفذتهما وصفها بمجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه
وقد ندد الرئيس الروسي بالهجومي ووصفه
بالارهابي من جانبه وصف المتحدث باسم
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه لمقاطعه
اوديسا الاتهامات بالتسلل قوات اوكرانيه
الى منطقه
تطور غير مسبوق في مسار الحرب وبعيد عن
جبهات القتال التقليديه هكذا بدا ما اعلنه
الجانب الروسي بشان توغل بري اوكراني يقع
للمره الاولى باتجاه الداخل الروسي
وتحديدا في مقاطعه
ليست المره الاولى التي يسلط الضوء فيها
على مقاطعه الروسيه المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
خلال عام الحرب الاول اعلنت روسيا اكثر من
مره تعرض المقاطعه لقصف اوكراني لكنها
المره الاولى التي تتحدث موسكو عن توغل
بري لما وصفت بمجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه
وصلت الى قريه ليوبتشاني قال حاكم مقاطعه
بريانسك ان تلك المجموعه تسللت للقريه
واطلقت النار على سياره متحركه كما احتجزت
عددا من الرهائن في متجر ومنازل هناك تحدث
حكيم الولايه عن مقتل مدني واصابه طفل
ونشرت على منصات التواصل
لوحدات روسيه تسمي نفسها الفيلق الروسيه
التطوعي وتقول انها مواليه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في المقطع يقول المسلحون انهم
بقريه اليوبتشاني لتحرير ارضهم داعين
لاعلان العصيان ضد السلطات الروسيه لاحقا
اعلن جهاز امن الدوله الروسيه ان الامور
باتت تحت السيطره واكد اخراج القوميين
الاوكرانيين من مقاطعه بريانسك الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن الكرملين اعلن ان
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين سيتراس الجمعه
اجتماعا طارئا لمجلس الامن القومي لبحث
عمليه بريانسك التي وصفها الرئيس بالحدث
الارهابي
اليوم ارتكبوا عملا ارهابيا جديدا جريمه
اخرى دخل المنطقه الحدوديه واطلقوا النار
على المدنيين رغم انها سياره مدنيه راوا
المدنيين والاطفال بداخلها واطلقوا النار
عليهم
القراءه الاوكرانيه لما وقع فيبريانس نفت
بالمقابل مسؤوليتكييف وشككت في القصه
واعتبرتها محض اكاذيب الروسيه
لماذا لا تكون الروايه هي ان مرتزقه
وسجناء هم من قاموا بهذا العرض الاستفزازي
او ان تكون الروايه الاخرى هي ان مجموعه
من الاستخبارات الروسيه قد ارتدت الزير
الاوكراني ووضعت شعارات صفراء واختلقت بعض
الوثائق ودعت انها اوكرانيا
بينما ترى المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان ما وقع
في بريانس استمرار للتحول في روسيا
وتنقيتها وتحريرها من ديكتاتوريه بوتين
حسب تعبيرها
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من امتياز
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق ومن موسكو
معنى
الروسي مرحبا بكما
كيف فهمتم الرساله من ورائي هذه العمليه
في
اعمال
ارهابيه واضحه وهي تثبت اننا كنا مصحين
عندما بدانا العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
لاننا نعلم الفاشيه وما هي حقيقتها وكيف
تؤثر على الحياه ان منطقه بريانس هي
معروفه
انها
مناطق قريبه من اوكرانيا ويعلمون كيف
تتعامل الحكومه الفاشيه
ولكن علينا ان نوقن ان عدونا ليس في كيف
ان العدو في الولايات المتحده لذلك روسيا
تنظر في الاستمرار في سياساتها باستخدام
العامل النووي لدفع العدو الامريكي لان
خروجنا وتعليق العمل باتفاق الامني
بالنسبه
لتحديد
القدرات النوويه هذا شيء صحيح لان
التهديدات الامريكيه تتزايد سيد اوليكسي
منك هل هناك نوع من تهيئه ربما لنقل
الجبهات الى داخل الروسي
الحكومه الاوكرانيه كررت مرات عديده ان
اوكرانيا لن تتعدى الحدود التابعه لروسيا
الفيدراليه ان الخطه هي اخراج المحتل
الروسي من حدودنا المعترفه دوليا اما ما
حدث وما تعرضوه على الشاشه الان ما حدث
اليوم في بريانس انهم مواطنين روس وهذا ما
اعلنوه في المقاطع المسجله عدا عن ذلك هم
مواطنين لديهم البطاقات والهويه الروسيه
سيدي فجاني اوكرانيا متمسكه بهذه الروايه
ان لا علاقه لها بما حدث في داخل بريانسكو
ان ما جرى ربما قد يكون وراءه مرتزقه من
داخل روسيا هل روسيا على استعداد لعرض اي
دليل على اتهامها هذا
الواضحه ان الاسلحه التي كانوا يحملوها
امريكي امريكيه الصنع والطفل الذي اصيب
اصيبت باسلحه امريكيه الصنع عدا عن ذلك
كان
الارهابيين يتحدثون باللغه الاوكرانيه
وهذا ما شهد عليه الرهائن الذين حجزوهم
واستطاع البعض الفر وشهدوا بهذا عدا عن
ذلك القوات الارهابيه دخلت من الحدود
الاوكرانيه وهذا
تدله ايضا
وسائل
التواصل التي كانت تستخدم المحطات
الاوكرانيه ولكني اريد ان اقول مؤكدا
ان الولايات المتحده هي من تقف وراء تصعيد
الميزان
ياخذ هذه الدلائل التي
شرحتها لنا الى السيد اوليكس سيد اوليكس
اليك الدليل الذي يتحدث عنه ضيفنا من
موسكو بان من يقف وراء هذه العمليه هم من
الاوكرانيين
الشاي الوحيد الذي ممكن ان اقوله واتفق
معه ان هذه الجماعه ممكن ان تكون دخلت من
الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وقد تكون قوات اوكرانيه امنت
لهم ممر امن ولكن في هذه القوات ليس هناك
اي جندي اوكراني بل هم من اعلنوا انهم
مواطنين روسي يحاربون ضد نظام بوتين
الدموي
واما الحديث عن الاسلحه الامريكيه
والرصاصات الامريكيه كانت تحدث السيد
بوتين ان الاسلحه متواجده في الداخل الرسل
لذلك هذه الاتهامات ليس ليس هناك اي اساس
ولكن انت يعني الان تقول انهم ربما دخلوا
من اوكرانيا وربما القوات الاوكرانيه هي
من امنت لهم سهوله الدخول الى الاراضي
الروسيه وهذا يقودنا سيد يفجاني في دروس
الى السؤال هذا الهجوم الذي حدث اليوم كيف
من شانه ان يؤثر على خطط روسيا وعملياتها
على الارض في المرحله المقبله
عندما تحدثت عن دور الولايات المتحده انا
لا اقول انهم هم نظموا كل هذا
ولكن هناك الكثير من التفاصيل التي تشترك
بها
نحن نفهم جيدا ان الحل بالنسبه لهذا
النزاع تقع في واشنطن كنا قد حللنا هذه
النزاعات ايضا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بعد الهجمات على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
حسب القوانين الدوليه ليس هناك دوله تسمى
اوكرانيا لان هذه المناطق لم تسمى دوله
رسميه
سؤال سؤال ابسط من ذلك بكثير يعني كيف
ستتعامل روسيا الان من الان وصاعدا مع
احتمال وامكانيه ان تنتقل المعارك الى
داخل اراضيها
نعتمد على ان هذه هذا السيناريو محتمل
ونحن نعتمد على اننا يجب ان نسرع اليات
الضغط على
الولايات المتحده باستخدام القدرات
النوويه وهذا كنا نتحدث عنه في الاجتماعات
في الاسبوع الماضي
اليس هذا لعبا بالنار على مختلف الجبهات
يعني
لعب بالنار على مستوى النووي لاعب بالنار
ربما على مستوى ما تطلبه الدول الداعمه في
الغرب لاوكرانيا
يجب ان اقول انه من الغريب ان اسمع اي
اتهامات باتجاه الولايات المتحده وكان
العدوان بدا من الولايات المتحده ضد روسيا
اريد ان اذكر الضيف الكريم ان روسيا هي من
اجتاحت اوكرانيا وبوتين هو من اعلن الحرب
وليس الولايات المتحده اما بالنسبه
للاسلحه والدعم من الشركاء لاوكرانيا
اعتقد ان على الشركاء ان يعجلوا تسليم هذه
الاسلحه لتعجيل انتهاء هذه الحرب والوسيله
الوحيده لنهايه هذه الحرب هو هزيمه روسيا
وطرضها خارج الحدود المعترفه دوليا ولكن
دون اي هجمات ضد المواقع والاراضي الروسيه
شكرا لك
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق من
امتياز وشكرا للسيد الجاني فيدروف عضو
مجلس ادوم الروسي ضيفنا من موسكو
الخلافات الدوليه بشان الملف الاوكراني
ادت الى انتهاء اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه دول
مجموعه العشرين في الهند بدون توافق بشان
الحرب في اوكرانيا وذكرت وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه ان الصين انضمت الى روسيا في رفض
صدور اعلان مشترك في ختام الاجتماعات كما
نقلت الوكاله عن مسؤول امريكي ان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن اجرى
لقاء مقتضبا مع نظيره الروسي سيرجيلا على
هامش اجتماعات مجموعه العشرين كما نقلت
رويترز عن نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان
واشنطن
قادرتان على وقف الصراع غدا اذا اتخذ تال
القراراته الصائبه وفق وصفه
وقد نقلت وكاله السوشيت عن مسؤول امريكيا
قولها ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن شدد في لقائه المقتضب مع نظيره
الروسي على استمرار واشنطن في دعمها
لاوكرانيا وعلى ضروره انهاء الحرب والعوده
الى معاهده ستارت اضاف ان الوزير بلينكن
لم يخرج من حديثه مع لافروف باي انطباع
بان موسكو ستغير مواقفها
[موسيقى]
تقرير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذي
يتحدث عن جزيئيات يورانيوم مخصب بدرجه
نقاء تقارب 90% في مفاعل فوردو في ايران
دفعه بالملف النووي الايراني مره اخرى الى
واجهه الاحداث وفي الوقت الذي تم فيه
طهران ما جاء في التقرير وما تصفه
بالادعاءات الكاذبه تستعد الدول الغربيه
لاستصدار قرار يلقي باللائمه على ايران
يظل غياب الحماس الامريكي لهذا التحرك
الاوروبي عشيه زياره تقود مدير الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه لطهران وفي جعبته
استفسارات بانتظار اجوبه
على عتاب المستويات المطلوبه لصناعه سلاح
نووي تقف طهران حسب اخر تقرير للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بنسبه نقاء بلغت
ثلاثه 83 و 17% وقريبه من نسبه 90% التي
تحتاجها الدول لصناعه قنبله نوويه تقول
الوكاله انها وجدت عينات يورانيوم في
منشاه فوردو قفزه كبيره في معدلات التخصيب
بلغتها ايران يشير التقرير بعد ان انفلت
الطهران من اغلال الاتفاق النووي الذي كان
يقيد عمل المفاعلات النوويه ويحد نسبه
التخصيب المسموح بها في ثلاثه وسته اعشار
في المئه تحت اليات صارمه للمراقبه بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي بشكل احادي في عهد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب رفع
الطهران بشكل تدريجي نسبه التخصيب الى نحو
60% لكن التقرير الاخير اشار الى ان ازاله
طهران معدات اصابتها الوكاله للكشف والم
حد من قدرتها على الوصول الى تفاصيل
عمليات التخصيب في المفاعلات النوويه كما
وكيفا وهو ما يبقي مجال التكهن بخصوص
كميات اليورانيوم التي خصبتها ايران حتى
الان علما ان انتاج سلاح نووي يتطلب على
الاقل 25 كيلو جراما بدرجه نقاء تتراوح ما
بين 90 وخمسه وتسعين في المئه تنفي طهران
هذه الاتهامات وترد بان معطيات التقرير
قديمه وان نقاط الخلاف فيه تم تسويتها على
مستوى الخبراء الذين زاروا ايران خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين نفي اخر جاء على لسان
رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد
اسلامي الذي اكد ان ما تم كشفه ذرات
معدودات لا يمكن ان ترى بالعين المجرده
لكن هذه التطمينات لا تبدد هواجس الغرب
والغرب هنا ليس جبهه موحده فيما يبدو
فباريس وصفت الامر بالخطير وغير المسبوق
وفي الوقت الذي تتحفز فيه فرنسا المانيا
وبريطانيا لاستصدار قرار في اعقاب اجتماع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الاسبوع
المقبل يوجه اللوم رسميا لطهران لاقترابها
من بلوغ العتبه النوويه تبدو اداره الرئيس
بايدن متردده في سلوك هذا الدرب صحيفه
التي نقلت الخبر استبعدت ان تنجح مساعد
دول الاوروبيه في صياغه البيان دون دعم
الولايات المتحده ولعل واشنطن تنتظر نتائج
زياره مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الى طهران حيث يتوقع ان يطالب رافاييل
روسي الرئيس الايراني بتقديم توضيحات بشان
العينات التي وجدها المفتشون الدوليون في
منشاه فورد النوويه قبيل اجتماع مجلس
محافظ الوكاله المقرر في فيينا الاثنين
المقبل
وكان المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي لويس
قد قال ان هناك اجماعا بالاتحاد الاوروبي
على ضروره مواصله مفاوضات والاتصالات مع
ايران واضاف في مقابله مع الجزيره ان
المطلوب من ايران حاليا هو التعامل الشفاف
مع وكاله الطاقه الذريه
يتعين الاتحاد الاوروبي تنسيق هذه
المفاوضات النوويه التي هي بالاسف الشديد
مجمده اليوم يعني طبعا يعني نحن منذ شهور
حتى سنوات نقول بان على
التعاون الكامل بشكل شفاف مع وكاله الذريه
الدوليه الذريه وبالتالي يعني هذا الموقف
لم يتغير المطلوب من الصوت الان وخصوصا في
هذا الاوقات من الممر الريحه نحن في
اوروبا التعاون الكامل مع هذا الوكاله
انا من لندن ويليام باتي السفير البريطاني
السابق لدى ايران ومن طهران معنا علي اكبر
داريني الباحث المختص في الدراسات
الايرانيه الامريكيه مرحبا بكما سيد علي
اكبر دارين ما التوضيحات التي تستعد ايران
لتقديمها لرفايا الجروسى
الطهران من اجل حوار ونقاشات مع المسؤولين
الاداريين وعلى راس قائمته مساله
اليورانيوم المخصه بنسبه
83% الذي تم التقاط جسيمات له وكان هناك
عدد من مفتشين الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه جاؤوا الى ايران في الايام الماضيه
وازر محادثات تقنيه هناك مؤشرات على ان
هذا القضيه قد تم حلها لان هناك سؤال كبير
هل ان هذا
التخصيب بنسبه 83% كان قرارا متعمدا من
جانب ايران ام كان مشكله تقنيه من دون ان
تكون هناك مقاصد من وراء ذلك هناك بعض
التغيرات والتقلبات
عالم متخصص بالفيزياء النوويه يمكن ان
يقول انه من الطبيعي في عمليات التخصيب
الايرانيوم ان تكون هناك تباينات حيث لا
يتوقف
المشغل لا يوقف الجهاز في الوقت المناسب
والكميات تتحدث عنها قابله لان يتم
تجاهلها لصغارها ولو كان القرار مقصودا
ربما سمحت ايران
بالتخصيب ليوم او يومين لكن يبدو انما تم
كان لمده ثواني فقط وان المفتشون ربما
اقتنعوا بهذا وستكون فرصه طيبه لشرح
الموقف الجراصي ايضا سيد هل التبرير هذا
قد يقنع باعتقادك الوكاله الدوليه والغرب
عموما
سيكون من المثير للاهتمام ان نسمع ما تقول
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بعد
زيارهم الى طهران هم في الماضي قالوا ان
ايران تخصب اليورانيوم بنسب تفوق كثيرا اي
حاجه لاستخدام سلمه وهذه ليست هي المره
الاولى التي تقول فيها الوكاله بان ايران
منخرطه في برنامج نووي تخصيب الايرانيون
بما يتلائم مع انتاج سلاحنا وليس استخدام
سلمي اعتقد ان ربما هناك شعور بانه قد تم
فقدان الامل فيما يتعلق
باحياء
الاتفاق النووي واذا ما تم هذا كاستنتاج
ربما نكون قد وصلنا نقطه الرجعه ولا عوده
لكن علينا ننتظر لنرى ما ستقوله الوكاله
اولا من المسؤول سيد بعتي عن فقدان الامل
لان طهران من وجهه نظرها هو ان من خرج من
هذا الاتفاق هو الذي يتعين عليه العوده
وطهران لم تكن هي من بدا بهذه العمليه لا
بل هي تريد العوده وفق شروط السابقه
هناك مسؤوليات متعدده دونالد ترامب سيتحمل
بعض المسؤوله المسؤوليه الانسحابه واراسه
تتحمل الكثير من المسؤوليه لعدم رغبتها
باستئناف الاتفاق بفرض الشروط تعجيزيه وان
تطلب برفع العقوبات عن الحرس الثوري وما
الى ذلك
العلاقات المتدهوره بين ايران وبين اولاد
المتحده والبلدان الاوروبيه وكل العوامل
الجديده كلها تفعل فعلها حتى تزويد ايران
بالمسيرات لروسيا واستمرارها في تزويد
السلاح لليمن هذه كلها تشكل خلفيه مشهد
التدهور للعلاقه كما قلنا سيد علي اكبر
دليل يعني لتفادي اي اشكالات على صعيد
اتهام ايران
من وجهه نظر ايران زورا بانها تزيد من
وتيره التخصيب بما يلامس امكانيه انتاج
سلاح نووي اليس منطقيا ان تعود عمليات
التفتيش وتنتظم العلاقه مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لتفادي كل هذه
الاشكالات
من الان
توفر القدره
للمفتشين لدخول منشاتها وهذا جزء من اتفاق
الضمانات ومفتشوا الوكاله يزورون
ويفتشون المنشاه الايرانيه للتحقق من
تخصيب اليورانيوم اذا لا عقبه تعترض ذلك
عقبات لان الوكاله تقول ان هناك قيود
كثيره على التفتيش منها مثلا ايقاف تسليم
الكاميرات واشرطه الكاميرات للوكاله
اوقفت تطبيق
اي شيء يتجاوز اتفاق الضمانات ايران كانت
تطبق في الماضي
البروتوكولا الاضافي لكن وفقا للقانون لا
يمكن لايران تفعل ذلك وايران ومنذ مده لا
تسمح للمفتشين الوكاله
ولكامراتهم في منشات لا تعتبر النوويه لكن
مشات النوويه هي تستمر في كونها خاضعه
للتفتيش لكن عدا عن اتفاق الضمانات ايران
لا تسمح للفتاه هذا صحيح لكن هل انتهكت
ايران معاهده الحد من انتشار السلاح
النووي حتى لو خصبت ايران الايرانيه بنسبه
90% الاجابه هي كلا هذا هو نص المعاهده
وهذا النص يخبرنا بان ايران ليس ممنوعا
عليها من تخصيب الايرانيون اليورانيون
بنسبه 90% النص يقول ممنوع عليها ان سلاح
النووي حتى رئيس الوكاله المؤخرا قال انه
لا يوجد اي مؤشر على ان ايران قررت تحويله
برنامجها النووي الى برنامج سلاحي المساله
مساله نوايا ولا توجد ادله علانيه ايران
في زياده تخصيب الايرانيوم في هذه اللحظه
شكرا لك علي اكبر دليل البحث المتخصص في
دراسات الايرانيه الامريكيه من طهران
وشكرا للسيد ويليام باتي السفير البريطاني
السابق لدى ايران من لندن
ملف ايران سيبقى حاضرا معنا حيث نناقش بعد
قليل في فقره في المتابعه الجدل بشان
سفينتين حربيتين لايران على شواطئ
البرازيل
[موسيقى]
صوت المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا خلال
جلسه طارئه عقدها في طرابلس بالموفقه على
تعديل على الاعلان الدستوري الامر الذي
يمهد لاجراء الانتخابات البرلمانيه وافاد
المكتب الاعلامي للمجلس ان المجتمعين
اتفقوا على الشروع في تشكيل لجنه لوضع
القوانين الانتخابيه في جلسته المقرره
الاثنين المقبل وحدد التعديل شكل السلطه
التشريعيه لكنه ترك شروط الترشح للرئاسه
دون حسم
بعد مسار متعثر وانقسام داخلي بين اعضائه
صوه المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا على
التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر للاعلان
الدستوري المؤقت الذي اصبح يشكل قاعده
دستوريه وخريطه طريق تجرى وفقا لها
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
تصويت لم يحظى بتوافق المجلس الاعلى
للدوله الذي وصفه اعضاء منه بالمخالف
لللائحه الداخليه له
ويرسم التعديل الدستوري نظام الحكم في
ليبيا بتشكيل سلطه تشريعيه تسمى مجلس
الامه تتكون من غرفتين وهما مجلس النواب
ومقره في بنغازي شرق البلاد ومجلس الشيوخ
ومقره في طرابلس غرب البلاد وبتشكيل سلطه
تنفيذيه يختار رئيسها من رئيس الدوله
واللافت ان التعديل الدستوريه الثالثه عشر
لم يتضمن اي اشاره الى شروط ترشح رئيس
الدوله محيلا ذلك على الق الانتخابيه التي
من المفروض ان تصاغ بالتوافق بين لجنه
مشتركه من 12 عضوا تتشكل بالتساوي من
مجلسي النواب والاعلى للدوله وفي حال فشل
اللجنه في تحقيق هدفها تتجه الى وضع اليه
لحسم الخلاف يكون مجلس النواب حينها مجبرا
على اقرارها اذ ان مجلس الدوله يرفض ترشح
العسكريين ومزدوجي الجنسيه فيما يدعم مجلس
النواب ترشح اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
لرئاسه الدوله رغم حمله الجنسيه الامريكيه
اعتقد ان هذا التعديل برمته غير كافي لان
يكون قاعده دستوريه واللجنه سته زائد سته
في تقدير لين تحل هذا الاشكال الذي لم تحل
حله اي لجان فيما بين المجلسين وحتى
رئيسين المجلسين عند مجتمع في جنيف هذا
الغلاف سيبقى قائم والافضل هو ان يتم
تجاوز المجلسين والذهاب الى اللجنه التي
يتحدث عن المبعوثه الامامي بقرار هذا
التعديل الدستوري لا يتوافق مع ما اقترحه
منذ ايام المبعوث الامامي الى ليبيا عبد
الله باتيلي على مجلس الامن الدولي بتشكيل
لجنه وصفها بالتوجيهيه تتولى صياغه خريطه
طريق للانتخابات هذا العام توجه راى فيه
مجلس النواب والاعلى للدوله تجاوزا
لمهامهما
سياسيه ليبيه في هذا التعديل الدستوري
ترحيلا للا
زمه فات بين مجلسي
النواب لاحقه وبالموازاه مع ذلك لم يعلن
المجتمع الدولي موقفه من خطه المبعوث
الامامي الى ليبيا ولم تبدي اطراف اقليميه
داعمه لحفتر اي حماسه لها حتى الان احمد
خليفه الجزيره طرابلس
من جانبها حثه السفارات الامريكيه في
ليبيا في تغريده القاده الليبيين على
التعاطي مع مخطط المبعوث الخاص للامين
العام للامم المتحده بطريقه بناء
من اسطنبول معنى نزار كريكش مدير مركز
بيان لدراسات السياسيه في ليبيا مرحبا بك
للمجلس الاعلى للدوله اين يضع موضوع
القاعده الدستوريه فيما يتعلق بالانتخابات
الحسيمه هذا الامر
نعم اظن ان هذا التصويت رغم ما شابه من
جدل الا انه يعني يعطي دفعه لهذا التعديل
الدستوري الثالث عشر الذي اقره مجلس
النواب لانه الان يصبح وفق الاتفاق
الصخيرات هناك توافق بين المجلسين حول
قاعده دستوريه ويبقى مساله هل هذا الامر
يحسم المشكله في ليبيا هذا موضوع اخر لكن
هو الان
يستطيع المجلسان ان يقدمه لبهيل ويقول له
انت قلت في مجلس النواب نحن لم نقوم
بقاعده دستوريه ها هي القاعده الدستوريه
فهم الان يتسابقون مع مقترح بتيل ويحاول
ان يردوا عليه بهذا المقترح لذلك كانت
هناك سرعه وكان حتى هناك يعني محاوله
لتجاوز اي خلاف داخل مجلس الاعلى للدوله
من خلال اجراءات يصفها البعض بغير قانونيه
وهنا
اسوء سيكون لهذا لهذه الخطوات على مبادره
بتله
نعم الان هو الاصل في الخلافه ان بتيلي
يعني يريد بصوره او باخرى ان يعطي السلطه
التاسيسيه التي تقر الانتخابات لي لجنه
جديده بينما مجلس النواب مجلس الاعلى
الدوله يريد ان يتمسك بان يكون هو من يضع
هذه الاسس الان تتحول المساله كلها من
مساله قانونيه في ليبيا الى خلاف بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
ننسى بان هذا الخلاف الذي حدث في ليبيا
الان هو نتاج للخلاف بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الذي بتى واضحا في مجلس
الامن بان الولايات المتحده كانت داعمه
وهناك انباء ومعلومات واضحه بان هي
الولايات المتحده هي من دفعت بتيلي في
كثير من اجزاء هذا المقترح نحو هذا المسار
بينما روسيا رفضت هذا امر روسيا ومصر
فالان هناك يعني شبه حرب بالوكاله سياسيه
في ليبيا بين المجلس الاعلى والمجلس
النواب من جانب وكثير من الشعب الليبي
الذي مل هذه الاجسام القائمه
شكرا جزيلا لك مدير مركزي بيان للدراسات
السياسيه في ليبيا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر حقوقيه تونسيه ان السلطات
اعتقلت الصادق شورو القيادي السابق في
حركه النهضه من جهتها اكد المحامي مختار
الجماعي في اتصال مع الجزيره خبر اعتقال
القيادي في حركه النهضه لحبيب اللوز وقال
انه لم تعرف بعد اسباب الاعتقال يذكر ان
اللوز كان نائبا في المجلس التاسيسي بعد
الثوره عن حركه النهضه وسبق له ان تراس
الحركه بعد اعتقال راشد الغنوشي في عهد
الرئيس الاسبق الحبيب بورقيبه
من جانبها عبرت الخارجات الامريكيه عن
قلقها من حمله الاعتقالات بحق ناشطين في
تونس بذريعه تواصلهم مع السفاره الامريكيه
هناك في الاثناء وبدعوى التامر على البلاد
رفضت السلطات السماح لجبهه الخلاص
المعارضه بالتظاهر يوم الاحد ضد
الاعتقالات وقد شجبت احزاب سياسيه ومنظمات
من المجتمع المدني استهداف المعارضين
والمنظمات الوطنيه واعلنت المشاركه في
مسيره دعا اليها اتحاد الشغل يوم السبت
لا يفتا الانغلاق السياسي في تونس يرتد
على البلاد توترات اجتماعيه واحتجاجات
عماليه ومناكفات سياسيه بين السلطه
وخصومها سريعا مضى اتحاد الشغل في تنفيذ
تهديداته السابقه بشن سلسله اضرابات فقد
امتنع عمال شركه السكك الحديديه عن العمل
يوم الخميس
تعطلت حركه القطارات في انحاء البلاد وعلى
كافه خطوط نقل البضائع والمسافرين البعيده
وفي ضواحي العاصمه هذا القطاع الحيوي
المملوك للدوله يؤمن حركه مئات الاف
التونسيين يوميا وعليه امتد التداعيات
الاضراب الى مصالح اخرى مختلفه بعد ان
تعذر الوصول اليها
وبينما تعتزم المنظمه النقابيه تنظيم
التجمع عمالي حاشد السبت المقبل امام
مقرها الرئيسي بالعاصمه استنكرت نحو 30
منظمه تونسيه ما وصفتها بحمله التشويه
والتحريض التي تستهدف المنظمات الوطنيه
والنقابيه في البلاد
ودعت النيابه العامه الى تحمل مسؤوليتها
التاريخيه في حمايه الحقوق والحريات
سياسيا اتهم التنسيقيه الاحزاب
الديمقراطيه في تونس الرئيس قيس سعيد
بسيطره على القضاء والانقلاب على مطالب
الثوره المتامل
يرى ان اليوم عايشين في كارثه فعلا ولكن
كارثه سياسيه عنوانها الابرز قيس سعيد
وحكم
في تونس اليوم كان ثبتوا للاسف الاحداث
تتسارع لكن هي حلقه
تسارعت اليوم في مسلسل يمكن عنوانه نجم
يكون كيف ترسل استبداد في تونس
الهجوم مع الاتحاد العام التونسي الشغل
هم يحبوا دفع قيس سعيد دفع الديمقراطيه في
الاتحاد
حاجته بالمنظمه كمنظمه
مقلقات سياسيا
ومقلقاته كذلك من حيث موقفها من قضاء
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه حاجته بالمنظمه
هذاك علاش نحن في الرباعي بالوضوح نهار
السبت مش نكونوا الى جانب الاتحاد ومش
نشاركو معه وندعو كل التونسيات والتونسيين
مش كونوا معنا الاتحاد لذلك قلنا ونكرر
سندافع عن الحريه باظافرنا واسناننا ودمنا
دعوات تقابلها السلطات بالتجاهل وبمزيد
الاطباق على الفضاء العام فقد اعلنت تلك
السلطات منع مظاهره دعت اليها جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه يوم الاحد المقبل للتنديد بحمله
الاعتقالات السياسيه والانتهاكات الجسيمه
للحريات العامه على حد وصف الجبهه وهي
تكتل لاحزاب وشخصيات معارضه
ومنذ اوائل شهر فبراير الماضي اعتقل الامن
التونسي نحو 20 شخصا من معارضين للرئيس
سعيد واعلاميين ورجال اعمال تقول المعارضه
انهم ضحايا التوجه الفردي الاستبدادي
لمنظومه الحكم الجديد بينما يظل سعيد يكرر
في كل اجتماع مع وزراء حكومته اتهام
المعتقلين بالتامر على امن الدوله
والتنكيل شعب وبضروره محاسبتهم
[موسيقى]
كانت الشهيه الاداره الامريكيه سمحت
البرازيل لسفينتين حربيتين ايرانيتين
بالرسو في ميناء
وجاء في اشعار نشر في جريده رسميه
برازيليه ان السفير وهما الفرقات دان
ومكاران ستمكثان في ميناء
قائد البحريه الايراني الادميرال شهران
ايراني قال ان تنقل السفينتين جزء من مخطط
الوجود العسكري للقوات البحريه الايرانيه
في المحيطات وفي يناير الماضي رصدت
السفينتان من قبل القوات الفرنسيه
والاستراليه اثناء عبورهما جنوب المحيط
الهادئ وبعد البرازيل ستغادر السفينتان
الى امريكا الوسطى لعبور قناه بنما يذكر
انه سبق لايران وفي عده مناسبات ارسال
ناقلات نفط وسوف تجاريه بحراسه بوارجها
الحربيه عبر المحيط الاطلسي والبحر الى
فنزويلا الخاضعه ايضا لحصار امريكي الوجود
العسكري الايراني في قناه بنما الدوليه
ووفقا لتقارير سيكون تحولا نوعيا لظهران
في مواجهه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والعقوبات الاقتصاديه من خلال اقامه شبكه
علاقات بامريكا اللاتينيه اما السفينه
تانى الاولى مكرا ويبلغ طولها 236 مترا هي
ناقله نفط تم تحويلها الى حامله تسعه
تسع خمسه مروحيات لتقديم الدعم اللوجيسي
في المعارك على الرغم من انها ليست سفينه
قتاليه الا انها اكبر سفينه حربيه ايرانيه
اما الفرقاه دنا فعدد طاقمها 148 محارا
وطولها سته وثمانون مترا انتهى تصنيعها
وادراجها قبل اقل من عامين في الاسطول
المكون من 86 قطعه مزوده بصواريخ كروز
مضاده للسفن وبتربيدات ومدافع بحريه وسبعه
زوارق عاليه السرعه وبطاقم قد يزيد عن 200
بحار وقال قائد البحريه الايراني السابق
انه يمكن لسطحها صعاب ست الى سبع مروحيات
من ساو باولو ينضم الينا رودريجو زاكلي
رئيس قسم العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه ساو
باولو الفيدراليه سيد رودريجو ما دلالات
هذا القرار البرازيلي
مرحبا بكم ويشرفني ان اظهر معكم مره اخرى
كما تعلمون البحريه
برازيليه تسمح
بزيارات لقطع بحريه
لمنائنا الرغم الولايات المتحده تمنع ذلك
لكن هناك
سفن ايرانيه خاضعه لنظام العقوبات
وتعتبر احدى هاتين السفيرتين السفينه
الاكبر في الاسطوره البريطاني لكن سمح لها
ان تدخل من السادس والعشرين من فبراير الى
الرابع من مارس وقد وافق رئيس البحريه على
اساس ان البرازيل
تتصرف كدوله ذات سياسه لها علاقات رسميه
مع ايران ومع الوقت المتحده
ولدينا علاقات تجاريه مع كلا البلدين ولكن
الا تخشى من رده فعل الولايات المتحده على
هذا القرار ما الذي يمكن ان تكون عليه رده
الفعل ضد البرازيل
هناك هذا الاحتمال فهناك محاوله واضحه من
جانب المتحده لجعل بلد كبير مثل البرازيل
يتصرف وفقا لمعطيات السياسه الخارجيه
وفيما يتعلق بنظام العقوبات وما الى ذلك
وهم يقولون ان هاتان السفينتان ساهمتان في
اعمال ارهابيه لكن لم تقدم ايه ادله
والقضيه المهمه
بالنسبه
للبرازيل
تعتبر ان الدوله في البرازيل هي صاحبه
القرار وهذا هو حتى الان هناك تكهنات شكرا
لك
رئيس قسم العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه ساو
باولو الفيدراليه كنت ضيفنا من مدينه ساو
با ولو في البرازيل
نبدا الساعه الثانيه من حصاد هذه الليله
وفي المواضيع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتل فلسطينيا
في قلقيليه واضراب في اريحا بعد اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال والاتحاد الاوروبي والامم
المتحده يناددان بتصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بشان محو حواره في نابلس
تونس مزيد من التصعيد عنوانه الاعتقالات
السلطات ترفض السماح لجبهه الخلاص بتنظيم
احتجاجات على حمله الاعتقالات يوم الاحد
بدعوى التامر على البلاد وجبه تقول ان
الدعوه قائمه تقول انها قلقه من اعتقالات
بحق ناشطين بذريعه تواصلهم مع سفاراتها
هناك
بريانسك تطور غير مسبوق خارج ارض المعركه
قبل ان تؤكد استعاده السيطره على الوضع
موسكو تتهم مجموعه اوكرانيه باحتجاز رهائن
في مقاطعه روسيه في اي علاقه لها وبعد
انهاء اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
العشرين دون توافق بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا
بلينكل لقاء مقتضب دون اختراقات
معايده صدور تقرير للوكاله الدوليه عن كشف
جزيئيات يورانيوم بنسبه تخصيب تقارب 90%
يصل الى طهران اليوم ايران تستبق الزياره
بالنفي وتقول الى نقاط الخلاف الوارده
سويت في اخر زياره للخبراء وفي ظل حديث عن
خلاف اوروبي امريكي بشان الرد متحدث باسم
الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول للجزيره ان دول
الاتحاد مجمعه على ضروره مواصله مفاوضات
مع طهران
[موسيقى]
قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فتى
فلسطينيا واصابت اخر بالرصاص الحي في بلده
عزون شرق مدينه قلقيليه بالضفه الغربيه
وقالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الفتى
محمد سليم البالغ من العمر 15 عاما استشهد
جراء اصابته برصاصه في الظهر بينما اصيب
اخر بجروح وصفت بالحرجه وقال شهود عيان ان
مواجهات عنيفا اندلعت مع قوات الاحتلال
خلال اقتحامها المدخل الشرقي للبلده حيث
اطلق جنود الاحتلال الرصاص الحي على شبان
البلده
هذا وكان شهدت مدينه اريحا اضرابا شاملا
حدادا على روح الشهيد محمود حمدان الذي
قتل برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر ياتي هذا بعد دعوات
من فصائل فلسطينيه عده الى اضراب شامل في
المدينه تمديدا بجرائم الاحتلال المستمره
بحق الفلسطينيين
وفي تعليق على تصريحات سابقه لوزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
دعا فيها لمحو بلده حواره قال المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده ستيفان
دو جاريك ان هذا الموقف استفزازي وتحريضي
وغير مقبول ويتعارض مع قرارات المنظمه
الدوليه
التصريح الذي ادنى به الوزير
استفزازيون وتحريضي وغير مقبول وصدور هذا
التصريح المسؤول حكومي هو امر غير مسؤول
كما انه يتعارض مع قرارات الامم المتحده
الامين العام يجدد مره اخرى دعوته جميع
الاطراف الى الامتناع عن الخطاب التحريضي
والاستفزازات لا سيما في ظل التوترات
الحاليه والعنف المتصاعد
وفي رد فعل اخر قال مكتب الاتحاد الاوروبي
في القدس ان دعوه سموتريتش لمحوي حواره
غير مقبوله اضاف الاتحاد الاوروبي في
تصريح خاص للجزيره ان هذه التصريحات تحرض
على العنف العشوائي في وضع متوتر للغايه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه واصفا اياها بانها
تسير في الاتجاه المعاكس وغير مقبوله ولا
تطاق وعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلقه
البالغ اذا تصاعد العنف وقال انه كان من
الضروري اتخاذ تدابير فوريه لخفض التصعيد
في بلده حواره كما دعا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى التنصل من هذه التصريحات
والعمل مع جميع الاطراف المعنيه لنزع فتيل
التوتر
معنا من حيفا الدكتور سليم بريك الخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك دكتور سليم
كيف بدايه قيمت ردت الفعل الدوليه على
دعوات سموكرتش لمحو حواره
مساء الخير رد الفعل الامريكي
غير مسبوقه
بالتعامل مع تصريح مطرج ولكن رد الفعل
الاوروبي يعني كان فاطر جدا
وايضا الام
م المتحده بالفتره الاخيره ردود فعلها لا
ترتقي لاي مستوى
وعمليا هي لا تثير اي اهتمام في جانب
الاسرائيلي
ما قام به عمليا هو تحريض على القتل هو
تحريض على حرق قريه بمن فيها باعتقاد هذا
يرتقي ايضا الى التحريض على جريمه حرب
رد الامم المتحده والدول الاوروبيه كان
اضعف بكثير من ان يؤثر على حتى راينا ان
بنيامين نتنياهو بالرغم من المطالبه
الواضحه بان يشلب هذه التصريحات ولم يجب
هذه التصريحات
ضمنيا يتفق مع هذه الاسلحه ولكن دكتور
سليم يعني كما ذكرت موضوع رده الفعل
الامريكيه
ما صداها في الداخل الاسرائيلي خصوصا
وانها كما قلت استخدمت كلمات ربما لم يتم
استخدامها سابقا
اعتقادي هناك تصعيد بين الولايات المتحده
والحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه لاحظي مثلا
لو اكثر من شهرين من اقامه الحكومه حتى
الان لم يدعى بنمية يهوى الى الولايات
المتحده هذا امر غير مسبوق وطبعا انا
اعتقد
لا يمكن ان يكون ضيوف في الولايات المتحده
باعتقاد هذا الامر واضح ولكن التصعيد
الامريكي عاده هو سفينه كبيره في البحر
يعني يتحرك تدريجيا ولكن نحن نرى هذا
التصعيد
التصريح الامريكي حصي حظي باهتمام كبير
جدا في كل وسائل الاعلام باسرائيل كانت له
تغطيه وهذا يدل بان هناك تصعيد في
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه وخصوصا
بان حكومه اسرائيل عملت ضد التوجه
الامريكي الذي حاولت من خلاله خفض عده
التوتر في اتفاق العقل
هذا التصعيد الذي تتحدث عنه دكتور سليم
كيف ينعكس
العلاقه بين الحكومه والمعارضه المتوتره
جدا هذه الايام
اولا الحكومه بحاجه لهذا التص
عيدك الخارجيه
وتستمر في عمليه الانقلاب في السلطه هذا
يخدم بنيامين نتنياهو ولكن في حكومه
اسرائيل هناك انشقاق
قسم من الحكومه واجهزه الامن تريد خفض حده
التوتر وهذا نراه مثلا برغبه قاده الجيش
برغبه قاده اجهزه الامن المختلفه ولكن من
الناحيه الثانيه عند
يمثلان احزاب فاشيه
ويريدون التصعيد هم يريدون القضاء على
سلطه الفلسطينيه نهائيا وعلى ما يبدو
نتنياهو موجود في الوسط وهو اضعف من ان
يقرر في هذه الامور
ومطرشؤون ويعملون ما يشاءون ونتنياهو لا
يستطيع عمليا ان يقف امامهم ولكن في سؤالي
قصدت دكتور سليم التوتر بين الحكومه
والولايات المتحده كيف ينعكس على العلاقه
بين الحكومه والمعارضه المتوتره جدا
بهذا الحال عاده المعارضه تحاول ان تكون
رسميه وان تنظر الى المصلحه العامه للدوله
وان لا تقف الى جانب الامريكان ضد الحكومه
الموجوده في في اسرائيل
هناك انتقادات شديده ايضا لا تنشر في
العالم مثلا قلق جدا من قضيه توتر
العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده يجب ان نذكر
بان اسرائيل الولايات المتحده عندها ملفات
هامه جدا على الصعيد المنطقه وتريد ان
يكون كل الاهتمام على هذه الملفات مثل ملف
الايراني والقلق من ايران وصلت الى 48% من
التخصيط وقضيه التغلغل الايراني في
المنطقه
والولايات المتحده بحاجه لاسرائيل بكل ما
يتعلق بالتقنيات العسكريه بالحرب
في اوكرانيا وكل هذه الامور التي تحدث في
الضفه
الغربيه
اسرائيل الولايات المتحده والمعارضه تحاول
عمليا لفت النظر لهذا الموضوع ولكن ليس
مجنده ضد الموضوع الفلسطيني شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور سليم بريك الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ضيفنا من حيفا
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر وحقوقيه تونسيه ان السلطات
اعتقلت الصادق شورو القيادي السابق في
حركه النهضه من جهه اكد المحامي مختار
الجماع في اتصال مع الجزيره خبر اعتقال
القيادي في حركه النهضه لحبيب اللوز وقال
انه لم تعرف بعد اسباب الاعتقال يذكر ان
اللوز كان نائبا في المجلس التاسيسي بعد
الثوره عن حركه النهضه وسبق له ان تراس
الحركه بعد اعتقال راشد الغنوشي في عهد
الرئيس الاسبق الحبيب بورقيبه واللوز هو
القيادي الرابع المعتقل من قاده النهضه
بعد علي العريض ونور الدين البحيري وفوزي
كمون مدير مكتب الغنوشي سابقا اضافه الى
القياديه المستقيل من النهضه عبد الحميد
الجلاصي من جهتها دانت حركه النهضه اعتقال
اللوز وما وصفته بتوسع حمله الاعتقالات
العشوائيه التي شملت رموز المعارضه
السياسيه واكد بيان الحركه وجود محاوله
لترهيب كل صوت حر بعد العجز في اداره
مشاكل البلاد الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه على
حد تعبير البيان
من جانبها عبرت الخارجات الامريكيه عن
قلقها من حمله الاعتقالات بحق ناشطين في
تونس بزريعه تواصلهم مع سفاره الامريكيه
هناك في الاثناء وبدعوه تامر على البلاد
رفضت السلطات السماح لجبهه الخلاص
المعارضه بالتظاهر يوم الاحد ضد
الاعتقالات وقد شجبت احزاب سياسيه ومنظمات
من المجتمع المدني استهداف المعارضين
والمنظمات الوطنيه واعلنت المشاركه في
مسيره دعا اليها اتحاد الشغل يوم السبت
بينما شلنا عمال السكك الحديديه اضرابا
الخميس عطل حركه القطارات في كل انحاء
تونس
لا يفتا الانغلاق السياسي في تونس يرتد
على البلاد توترات اجتماعيه واحتجاجات
عماليه ومناكفات سياسيه بين السلطه
وخصومها سريعا مضى اتحاد الشغل في تنفيذ
تهديداته السابقه بشن سلسله اضرابات فقد
امتنع عمال شركه السكك الحديديه عن العمل
يوم الخميس
تعطلت حركه القطارات في انحاء البلاد وعلى
كافه خطوط نقل البضائع والمسافرين البعيده
وفي ضواحي العاصمه هذا القطاع الحيوي
المملوك للدوله يؤمن حركه مئات الاف
التونسيين يوميا وعليه امتد التداعيات
الاضراب الى مصالح اخرى مختلفه بعد ان
تعذر الوصول اليها
وبينما تعتزم المنظمه النقابيه تنظيم
التجمع عمالي حاشد السبت المقبل امام
مقرها الرئيسي بالعاصمه استنكرت نحو 30
منظمه تونسيه ما وصفتها بحمله التشويه
والتحريض التي تستهدف المنظمات الوطنيه
والنقابيه في البلاد ودعت النيابه العامه
الى تحمل مسؤوليتها التاريخيه في حمايه
الحقوق والحريات
سياسيا اتهم التنسيقيه الاحزاب
الديمقراطيه في تونس الرئيس قيس سعيد
بسيطره على القضاء والانقلاب على مطالب
الثوره المتامل
يرى ان اليوم عايشين في كارثه فعلا ولكن
كارثه سياسيه عنوانها الابرز قيس سعيد
وحكم
في تونس اليوم كان ثبتوا للاسف الاحداث
تتسارع لكن هي حلقات
تسارعت اليوم في مسلسل يمكن عنوانه نجم
يكون كيف ترسل استبداد في تونس
الهجوم مع الاتحاد العام التونسي
هم يحبوا دفع قيس سعيد دافع الديمقراطيه
في الاتحاد
حاجته بالمنظمه كمنظمه
مطلقات سياسيا
ومقلقاته كذلك من حيث موقفها من قضاء
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه حاجته بالمنظمه
هذاك علاش نحن في الرباعي بالوضوح نهار
السبت مش نكونوا الى جانب الاتحاد ومش
نشاركوا معه وندعو كل التونسيات
والتونسيين مش كونوا معنا الاتحاد لذلك
قلنا ونكرر
سندافع عن الحريه باظافرنا واسناننا ودمنا
دعوات تقابلها السلطات بالتجاهل وبمزيد
الاطباق على الفضاء العام فقد اعلنت تلك
السلطات منع مظاهره دعت اليها جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه يوم الاحد المقبل للتنديد بحمله
الاعتقالات السياسيه والانتهاكات الجسيمه
للحريات العامه على حد وصف الجبهه وهي
تكتل لاحزاب وشخصيات معارضه
ومنذ اوائل شهر فبراير الماضي اعتقل الامن
التونسي نحو 20 شخصا من معارضين للرئيس
سعيد واعلاميين ورجال اعمال تقول المعارضه
انهم ضحايا التوجه الفردي الاستبدادي
لمنظومه الحكم الجديده بينما يظل سعيد
يكرر في كل اجتماع مع وزراء حكومته اتهام
المعتقلين بالتامر على امن الدوله
والتنكير شعب وبضروره محاسبتهم
معنى من تونس الامين البوعزيزي الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي ومن تونس محمد امين
الجربي عضو تحالف احرار مرحبا بكما سيد
محمد امين الجربي لماذا رفضت السلطات
السماحه لجبهه الخلاص بالتظاهر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اولا قبل الحديث على
لماذا رفضت ولايه تونس تصريحا للمتظاهرين
نقول اولا ان القضيه التي اصلا تريد جبهه
الخلاص التظاهره ضدها هي قضيه جاريه
والتحقيق لا يزال في الادوار الاوليه هناك
في بطاقات الايداع والقضيه ما زالت في
الاطوار الاوليه فهل نتظاهر بالضغط على
القضاء لماذا لماذا تتظاهر شبكه الخلاص
اصلا في حين ان القضيه لم يصدر فيها اي
حكم قضائي بيت واذا تم وبالفعل ستتم ان
شاء الله وبالادله ان المتهمين مدنون فكيف
سيكون موقف جبهه الخلاص الوطني وان كانوا
بريئين فنقول هذه من شؤون القضاء وسنعتذر
لهم ولكن حسب ما سرب من الوثائق فهم
مدانون بالفعل فلماذا تريد جبل خلاص
تتظاهر
الاطلاق الاحكام هذه التي تقوم بها دعنا
ناخذ هذا الامر الى السيد الامين بوعزيزي
سيد الامين لماذا تريد جبهه الخلاص
التظاهر ان كان الامر ما زال منظورا امام
القضاء
تحيه سيدتي شكرا على الدعوه شكرا لضيفك
الكريم نقول بناء على سؤالكم نعم لو كان
هناك قضاء في تونس لما تم التظاهر قيس
سعيد هدد بالعلن ان كل من يدافع اي قاضي
محامي اي انسان يدافع عن من حكم عليهم ومن
اغتالهم سلفا يعني تقريبا بالامس قاضي برء
متهما فتم عزله مباشره وبالتالي في تونس
اليوم لا يوجد قضاء التظاهر على اعتبار ان
الناس مختطفون وان الحاكم بامره من كتب
دستوره من امسك القضاء من امسك البرلمان
يعني التشريع من امسك التنفيذ من امسك
الاعلام من امسك كل شيء هو الحاكم بامره
هو الذي قال انا ربكم الاعلى لا اريكم الا
ما اراه وبالتالي الناس يتظاهرون ضد دوله
يعني انا ربكم الاعلى لا يوجد لا اشكال
كان في تونس قضاء لا احترم الناس القضاء
وانما هذا اغتال الناس يعني اغتالهم سلفا
حكم عليهم سلفا في تونس ما يجري اليوم هو
مناخ من الاستباحه لقتل الناس بضمير مرتاح
نفس ما فعلته النازيه يعني
تخوين تهيئه الراي العام
لائي حشرات سرطانات تقريبا تعرفون ما جرى
في مصر الخرفان بعد ذلك عندما يعني تمت
المجزره وشيء الناس في الساحات كان ذلك
يجري بامر
وبضميل
وضحت فكرتك سيد محمد في المانيا كان هكذا
وضحت سيد سيد محمد اذا المعارضه تقول لم
يعد هناك قضاء في تونس وربما من يعني ابرز
الدلائل على ذلك انك انت الان قبل قليل
تحدثت ان ادانهم القضاء نقول كان معنا حق
وان برئهم نعتذر لهم بمعنى ان كانت تخرج
الى الاعلام
وتدين هؤلاء سلفا قبل ان يقول القضاء
كلمته لماذا يحرم على المعارضه ان تعبر عن
رفضها لما يجري
اختي قرينه قرينه البراءه موجوده وكل متهم
بريء
انا ما قلت قلت الا ان قلت فقط ان ان كان
ان كانوا مذنبين فهمون وان كانوا
يعني بمعنى انك انت تفترض سلفا انهم
مذنبين
انا لا افترض انا فقط انتظر
التهم ولا النظر في الدلائل
القضاء لماذا لانك تعتبرهم اساسا الان انه
مذنبين اليس كذلك والسؤال هنا ليس رايك
السؤال لماذا يحرم على المعارضه ان تعبر
عن رايها بنفس الطريقه في الشارع
بالتظاهري رفضا لهذه القرارات
تم الترخيص لمظاهره الاتحاد تم ترخيص
المظاهرات الخماسي جبهه خلاص ظهرت في يوم
14 جانفي الان فقط انه القضيه جاريه
والبحر جاريه وننتظر خطا الابحاث الاوليه
فانتم اذا اردتم ان تتظاروا فهذا ضغط
صائم ان
تطلب الخلاص
ولا يعتبر ايضا
يعني الحديث عن الموقوفين وكانهم مدانين
الا يعتبر ايضا ضغطا على القضاء يقول لك
ضيفنا السيد الامين بوعزيز يتحدث عن
القاضي الذي برا متهما وتم عزله
لن تتضح الى الان لماذا تم عزم هذه
التحقيق الذي برأ براء حطها بن عثمان وبرئ
من قضيه مسك في قضيه اخرى هل انت تساعنين
الى ان هناك نقابه فوق القانون او ان هناك
سياسه فوق القانون او ان هناك حقوق فوق
القانون كفى بالدوله حيث شاهدنا في 2012
ان رجل اعمال كان يتفاوض مع وزير العدل
على قاضي التحقيق
القانون سيد محمد ولكن المناخ العام
لمن يؤيدون لهذه القرارات في تونس يميل
الى اصدار الاحكام قبل ان يقول القضاء
كلمته اليس كذلك
المراه المناخ العام الاجل ولكن انا انا
امثل طرفا مساندا للرئيس قلت لك اننا
ننتظر ختم الابحاث الاوليه لنتحدث على بين
سيد الامين البوعزيزي طيب الان يتم رفض
السماح
للمعارضه بالتظاهر ماذا عن الخطوات
المقبله ماذا بياد هذه المعارضه ان تفعل
فقط تقول ان جبه الخلاص يعني كل الفصائل
وكل الاطراف المناضله يعني في سبيل
الديمقراطيه معاركها لصالح القضاء وليس
ضغطا على القضاء القضاه هناك من هو يعني
زجه به قصرا رغما عن القضاء في مستشفى
الامراض العقليه قاضي يعني عزل امس صارت
مجزره في القضاء وحل مؤسساته وبالتالي
التظاهر ليس ضغطا على القضاء ولان من
انتصار الى القضاء هناك تهديد من على اعلى
راس الدوله يقول من يبرئ من جرمتهم هو
شريك لهم هذا يعني معناها امر واضح
المساله الثانيه سيدتي الناس يتظاهرون
الكفاح الديمقراطي هو كفاح ملتزم بالقانون
اليوم الخارج عن القانون هو
يعني راس الدوله وليس الناس حتى دستوره
الذي حبره بيده لا يجرم حق الناس في
التظاهر وبالتالي القانون الموجود لكنه لا
يريده ان يسود من يخرجون الى الشارع
ملتزمون بالقانون وينطلقون لكن عمليا الان
يعني هذا كله مفهوم ولكن عمليا ماذا بيدكم
ان تفعل
مثل ما يعني في شهر سبتمبر 2021 بعد تجاوز
البهته وولدت مواطنون ضد الانقلاب لكسر
حاجز الخوف سيواصل الناس التظاهر لكسر الى
انه اليوم كل ما يجري هو نوع من الترويع
العام ليخاف الناس عشر سنوات لن تموت هكذا
يعني في لحظه الناس الذين والجيل الذي
تربى على التظاهر والاجيال التي فرضت حق
التظاهر لا يمكن ان يرعبها يعني هذا الجو
المعركه اليوم ليست سياسيه يعني على
السلطه هي معركه لانقاذ تونس الجريحه تونس
المعزوله دوليا تونه
تقريبا التصريحات العنصريه اليوم يعني بعد
ان كنا مفخره اصبحنا مسخره وبالتالي الناس
لن يخافوا وسيخرجوا دفاعا عن تونس دفاعا
عن سمعه تونس دفاعا عن وجود هذا البلد
الذي تم العبث به شكرا لك الامين البوعزيز
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسيه من تونس وشكرا
للسيد محمد امين الجربي عضو تحالف احرار
من تونس ايضا
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الحرف في اوكرانيا حيث اعلن حاكم
مقاطعه بريان الروسيه المتاخمه للحدود
الاوكرانيه مقتل شخصين في اطلاق نار
نفذتهما وصفها بمجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه
وقد ندد الرئيس الروسي بالهجومي ووصفه
بالارهابي من جانبه وصف المتحدث باسم
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه لمقاطعه
اوديسا الاتهامات بتسلل قوات اوكرانيه الى
منطقه بالاكاذيب
تطور غير مسبوق في مسار الحرب وبعيد عن
جبهات القتال التقليديه هكذا بدا ما اعلنه
الجانب الروسي بشان توغل بري اوكراني يقع
للمره الاولى باتجاه الداخل الروسي
وتحديدا في مقاطعه بريانسك ليست المره
الاولى التي يسلط الضوء فيها على مقاطعه
لاوكرانيا خلال عام الحرب الاول اعلنت
روسيا اكثر من مره تعرض المقاطعه لقصف
اوكراني لكنها المره الاولى التي تتحدث
موسكو عن توغل بري لما وصفت بمجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه وصلت الى قريه
قال حاكم مقاطعه بريانسك ان تلك المجموعه
تسللت للقريه واطلقت النار على سياره
متحركه كما احتجزت عددا من الرهائن في
متجر ومنازل هناك تحدث حكيم الولايه عن
مقتل مدني واصابه طفل ونشرت على منصات
التواصل
لوحدات روسيه تسمي نفسها الفيلق الروسيه
التطوعي وتقول انها مواليه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في المقطع يقول المسلحون انهم
بقريه اليوبتشان لتحرير ارضهم داعين
لاعلان العصيان ضد السلطات الروسيه لاحقا
اعلن جهاز امن الدوله الروسيه ان الامور
باتت تحت السيطره واكد اخراج القوميين
الاوكرانيين من مقاطعه بريانسك الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن الكرملين اعلن ان
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين سيتراس الجمعه
اجتماعا طارئا لمجلس الامن القومي لبحث
عمليه بريانسك التي وصفها الرئيس بالحدث
الارهابي
اليوم ارتكبوا عملا ارهابيا جديدا جريمه
اخرى دخل المنطقه الحدوديه واطلقوا النار
على المدنيين رغم انها سياره مدنيه راوا
المدنيين والاطفال بداخلها واطلقوا النار
عليهم
القراءه الاوكرانيه لما وقع في بريانست
بالمقابل مسؤوليه كييف وشككت في القصه
واعتبرتها محض اكاذيب روسيه
لماذا لا تكون الروايه هي ان مرتزقه
وسجناء هم من قاموا بهذا العرض الاستفزازي
او ان تكون الروايه الاخرى هي ان مجموعه
من الاستخبارات الروسيه قد ارتدت الزير
الاوكراني ووضعت شعارات صفراء واختلقت بعض
الوثائق ودعت انها اوكرانيا
بينما ترى المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان ما وقع
في بريانس استمرار للتحول في روسيا
وتنقيتها وتحريرها من ديكتاتوريه بوتين
حسب تعبيرها
الخلافات الدوليه بشان الملف الاوكراني
ادت الى انتهاء اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه دول
مجموعه العشرين في الهند بدون توافق بشان
الحرب في اوكرانيا وذكرت وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه ان الصين انضمت الى روسيا في رفض
صدور اعلان مشترك في ختام الاجتماعات كما
نقلت الوكاله عن مسؤول امريكي ان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلنكن اجرى لقاء
مقتضبا مع نظيره الروسي على هامش اجتماعات
مجموعه العشرين كما نقلت رويترز عن نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان واشنطن
قادرتان على وقف الصراع غدا اذا اتخذتها
القرارات الصائبه حسب وصفه
وقد نقلت وكاله السوشي عن مسؤول امريكي
قوله ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
شدد في لقائه المقتضب مع نظيره الروسي على
استمرار واشنطن في دعمها لاوكرانيا وعلى
ضروره انهاء الحرب والعوده الى معاهده
ستارت واضاف ان الوزير بلينكن لم يخرج في
حديثه مع لافروف باي انطباع بان موسكو
ستغير مواقفها
من روما معنا اون مافيوز الصحفي المختص في
الشان الروسي ومؤلف كتاب القصه الداخليه
لحرب بوتين ضد اوكرانيا مرحبا بك سيد اون
مافيوز كيف يمكن تقييم هذا اللقاء بين
بلينكن وكان لقاء عربيا على هامش قمه
مجموعه العشرين
نعم هذا صحيح لكن من الهام جدا انهم تحدثا
الى بعضها البعض وايضا
كان هناك ايضا زار بعض بالنسبه لي هذه
حقائق مهمه جدا انهما التقيا وليس المهم
انهما تحدث او المواضيع التي تحدث بشن
اللقاء في حد دره يكتسي اهميه كبيره لان
الطرفان اصبح متباعدين بشكل كبير عن بعض
منذ انطلاق الحرب الان روسيا يبدو على
انها تحقق تقدم على الارض او على الاقل
انها لا تخسر هذه الحرب الى المرحله
الراهنه الامريكيون يعتقدون ان الاوكراني
بامكانهم ان يحسموا الحرب لصالحهم والان
هناك
بالتاكيد المساحه وامكانيه قلي لكي يلتقي
طرفا لكن هل يمكن ان يؤسس لاي امر هذا
الاجتماع بالنظر الى يعني ظروفه حاليا
نعم من الممكن ان يؤسسوا هذا اللقاء لشيء
ايجابي لكن المحادثات الحقيقيه لن تبدا
الا بعد ان
تسكت المدافع واعتقد بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
وروسيا ينبغي ان يكون هناك طبعا تنازلات
بالنسبه لوكرانيا التنازل في نظر روسيا هو
التخلي عن بعض اراضي اوكرانيا وهذا ليس في
والدي التصورات اوكرانيا في الوقت
متحده كل هذه الاهميه لموضوع عوده روسيا
الى اتفاقيه ستارت يعني هو واحد من ثلاث
مواضيع ربما على راس الاجنده الامريكيه
جرى الحديث بها مع لافروف من قبل بلينكن
اتفاقيه ستارت لديها اهميه
رمزيه وليست اهميه عمليه ما قاله الروس هو
انهم سيبداون
باختبارات نوويه اذا ما قام الامريكيين
بنفس الشيء الامريكي ليسوا بصدد الانخراط
في اختبارات النوويه الشيء المهمه بالنسبه
لاتفاقيه ستارت هو ليس بدايه اي من
الاطراف بارقام الاختبارات او استعمال
اسلحه نوويه الشيء المهم هو ان روسيا في
الوقت الراهن
ترسل رسائل بانها تمتلك اسلحه نوويه ولا
يمكن التعامل معنا كالعراق ولك سوريا ولك
يا غزلان
نحن بلد لا يمكن اجتياحه لاننا نتوفر على
اسلحه نوويه هذه هي رساله من قبل
المسؤولين الروس من خلال ما سمعناه في
الاونه الاخيره ليس هناك تهديد باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه لان
يدرك خطوره استخدام حتى اسلحه صغيره هذا
سيعتبر على انه انتحار اعتقد ان الرساله
التي ترسلها روسيا هنا لا يمكن هجمه روسيا
على اراضيها ومع ذلك رغم هذه الرساله
راينا اليوم هذه العمليه تجري في بريانس
وتتهم روسيا اطرافا اوكرانيا بالوقوف وراء
هذه ربما يعني اول عمليه تجري بهذا الشكل
في داخل الاراضي الروسيه اي دلالات
باعتقادك تحمل هذه العمليه وكيف
ستؤثر على استراتيجيات روسيا في المعركه
هذه هي المره الاولى كان هناك مجموعه من
الهجمات في الفتره الماضيه كان هناك
مهاجمه لاحد القواعد العسكريه داخل روسيا
وايضا مخازن للاسلحه
يقومون بارسال الطائرات المسيره باتجاه
روسيا منذ فتره من الواضح من خلال رد
الفعل الامريكي هو ان هذا النوع من
الهجمات الاوكرانيه يعتبر خطيرا جدا لكن
هناك واجه اخر لهذا الهجوم الاوكراني
اعتقد ان دون خدمات لرئيس البوت في بدايه
الحرب كان بوتين يقول بان العمل العسكريه
هي عمليه عسكريه محدوده صغيره الان بعد
سنه من انطلاق العمليه العسكريه بوتين
يقول
لمواطنيه ان الامر يتعلق
بحرب حياته موت ضد الغرب
ومهاجمه اهداف روسيا داخل روسيا يعني بان
بوتين سيقدم هذه الحرب لنا حرب مشروعه وان
لها طابع قومي وصراعه كبير ضد الغرب هذا
الغرب الذي يهدد كل مواطن روسي اشكرك جزيل
الشكر اول مافيوز الصحفيه المختص في الشان
الروسي ومؤلف كتاب القصه الداخليه لحرب
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا ضيفنا من روما
[موسيقى]
تقرير الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه الذي
تحدث عن جزيئيات يورانيوم مخصب بدرجه نقاء
تقارب 90% في مفعل فوردو دفع بالملف
النووي الايراني مره اخرى الى واجهات
الاحداث في الوقت الذي تنفي فيه طهران ما
جاء في التقرير وما تصيفه بالادعاءات
الكاذبه تستعد الدول الغربيه لاستصدار
قرار يلقي باللائمه على ايران في ظل غياب
الحماس الامريكي لهذا التحرك الاوروبي
عشيه زياره تقود مدير مدير الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه لطهران وفي جعبته
استفسارات بانتظار اجوبه
على عتاب المستويات المطلوبه لصناعه سلاح
نووي تقف طهران حسب اخر تقرير للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بنسبه نقاء بلغت
ثلاثه 83 و17 وقريبه من نسبه 90% التي
تحتاجها الدول لصناعه قنبله نوويه تقول
الوكاله انها وجدت عينات يورانيوم في
منشاه فوردو قفزه كبيره في معدلات التخصيب
بلغتها ايران يشير التقرير بعد ان انفلت
الطهران من اغلال الاتفاق النووي الذي كان
يقيد عمل المفاعلات النوويه ويحد نسبه
التخصيب المسموح بها في ثلاثه وسته اعشار
في المئه تحت اليات صارمه للمراقبه بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي بشكل احادي في عهد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب رفع
الطهران بشكل تدريجي نسبه التخصيب الى نحو
60% لكن التقرير الاخير اشار الى ان ازاله
طهران معدات اصابتها الوكاله للكشف
والمراقبه حد من قدرتها على الوصول الى
تفاصيل عمليات التخصيب في المفاعلات
النوويه كما وكيفا وهو ما يبقي مجال
التكهن بخصوص كميات اليورانيوم التي
خصبتها ايران حتى الان علما ان انتاج سلاح
نووي يتطلب على الاقل 25 كيلو جراما بدرجه
نقاء تتراوح ما بين 90 وخمسه وتسعين في
المئه تنفي طهران هذه الاتهامات وترد بان
معطيات التقرير قديمه وان نقاط الخلاف فيه
تم تسويتها على مستوى الخبراء الذين زاروا
ايران خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين نفي اخر
جاء على لسان رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد اسلامي الذي اكد ان ما تم
كشفه ذرات معدودات لا يمكن ان ترى بالعين
المجرده لكن هذه التطمينات لا تبدد هواجس
الغرب والغرب هنا ليس جبهه موحده فيما
يبدو فباريس وصفت الامر بالخطير وغير
المسبوق وفي الوقت الذي تتحفز فيه فرنسا
والم وبريطانيا لاستصدار قرار في اعقاب
اجتماع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الاسبوع المقبل يوجه اللوم رسميا لطهران
لاقترابها من بلوغ العتبه النوويه تبدو
اداره الرئيس بايدن متردده في سلوك هذا
الدرب صحيفه التي نقلت الخبر استبعدت ان
تنجح مساعد دول الاوروبيه في صياغه البيان
دون دعم الولايات المتحده ولعل واشنطن
تنتظر نتائج زياره مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه الى طهران حيث يتوقع ان
يطالب رافاييل روسي الرئيس الايراني
بتقديم توضيحات بشان العينات التي وجدها
المفتشون الدوليون في منشاه فورد النوويه
قبيل اجتماع مجلس محافظ الوكاله المقرر في
فيينا الاثنين المقبل
وكان المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي لويس
ميغيل وقد قال ان هناك اجماعا بالاتحاد
الاوروبي على ضروره مواصله المفاوضات
والاتصالات مع ايران واضاف في مقابله مع
الجزيره ان المطلوب من ايران حاليا هو
التعامل الشفاف مع وكاله الطاقه الذريه
يتعين الاتحاد الاوروبي تنسيق هذه
المفاوضات النوويه التي هي للاسف الشديد
مجمده اليوم يعني
نحن منذ شهور حتى سنوات نقول بان على
التعاون الكامل بشكل شفاف مع وكاله الطاقه
الذريه الدوليه الذريه وبالتالي يعني هذا
الموقف لم يتغير المطلوب من الصوت الان
وخصوصا في هذا الاوقات من الممر الريحه
نحن في اوروبا التعاون الكامل مع هذا
الوكاله
ينضم الينا من مدينه دوسلدورف في المانيا
عدنان طبطبائي مدير مركزي كاربو للدراسات
والباحث المختص في الشان الايراني سيد
عدنان هل نحن امام تحول حاسم في الموضوع
المتعلق بتخصيب اليورانيوم في ايران
بالنظر الى هذه النسبه التي يتم الحديث
عنها
حقيقه الامر لا يمكن ان نجزم بان هذه
الادعاءات صحيحه لكن دعونا نعتبر انها
صحيحه هذا يعني اننا في وضع
تقوم به ايران بمحاوله زياده الضغط على
الجانب الغربي اوروبا
الامريكيه
وايران تظهر ان لديها الان
المعرفه والخبره للقيام
باختبارات حقيقيه والاقتراب من انتاج
اسلحه اذا هذه رساله قويه صادره عن ايران
ترى القويه التي تتحدث عنها ما الذي يمكن
ان تجره على ايران وايضا على الملف المعلق
المتعلق بالتفاوض للعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي
راينا هو في الشهور القليله الماضيه هو ان
المحادثات الدوليه ما بين ايران
والغرب كان هناك حديث كثير حول تزويد
ايران لروسيا
طائرات غير ماهوله وايضا
رده الفعل الايراني اتجاه
احتجاجات في الداخل بالتالي لم يكن هناك
حديث كبير
بخصوص
اليورانيوم والبرنامج
النووي الايراني اعتقد ان ما تقوم به
ايران الان هي محاوله للتذكير الغرب بما
تقوم بهران فيما يتصل به الاسلحه النوويه
وتخصيب اليورانيوم وكيف سيتصرف باعتقادك
الغرب مع ذلك بالنظر الى كل هذه المعطيات
التي تحدثت عنها لاسيما الاتهامات بان
ايران تشارك في الحرب على اوكرانيا الى
جانب روسيا
[موسيقى]
التداعيات قد تكون بتاكيد في
صيغه مجموعه من الانتقادات من قبل
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وقد يتم
ارسال الملف الايراني مره اخرى الى مجلس
الامن ويمكن النقاش الموضوع هناك وطرحه
لانها تهديد
للامن الدولي وربما تناقش تحت الباندا
السابع ايران مدركه لهذا الامر واعتقد ان
هذه اللعبه لزياده الضغط من اجل جلب
المزيد من الانتباه للملف النووي الايراني
شكرا لك عدنان طبطبائي مدير مركز كاربو
للدراسات والباحث والمختص في الشان
الايراني ضيفنا من مدينه دوسلدورف في
المانيا
[موسيقى]
تعيش شبه الجزيره الكوريه على وقع توتر
كبير بعد التجارب الصاروخيه التي نفذتها
كوريا الشماليه واختراقها المجال الجوي
لكوريا الجنوبيه بطائرات مسيره ويزيد من
حده هذا التوتر حرص شعول على متانه
تحالفها مع واشنطن وتلافي اغضاب جارتها
الكبرى بيجين التي تدعم في سلسله تقارير
مراسلين الخاصه بملف التوتر في شرق اسيا
نسلط الضوء في هذا التقرير من سول على
جوانب من تعقيدات الوضع في شبه جزيره
الكوريه
هادئه تمضي الرحله الى الحدود بين
الكوريتين
لا تكاد تنبا بان رحى صراع دولي ممتد تدور
هنا لولا ان حروب الماضي ما زالت تلقي
بظلالها على المستقبل
هنا تدريب المشترك على الحدود يجمع
الجيشين الامريكي والكوري الجنوبي يحاكي
سيناريو حرب حقيقيه اصوات اطلاق الرصاص
تصل الى الجانب الاخر من الحدود في رساله
واضحه الى كوريا الشماليه
في هذا التدريب تمكننا من تحديد اسلوب
القتال الميداني وتحققنا ايضا من قابليه
التنسيق بين قواتنا العسكريه المشتركه
[موسيقى]
جديده في ذلك التحالف العسكري الام
ريكي الجنوبي ليس طارئه بل ان كوريا
الجنوبيه تعتمد بشكل كبير على الحمايه
الامريكيه لكن مظله الحمايه الامريكيه
بهذا الشكل لا تحظى بالاجماع على الحدود
مع كوريا الشماليه تنشط جمعيه الاتحاد من
اجل السلام يحذر مؤسسها من ان ضررا بوجود
الامريكي غدا اكبر من نفاه
الحل الوحيد لازمه شبه الجزيره الكوريه
ومغادره القوات الامريكيه وعدم تدخلها بين
الكوريتين كنا بلدا واحدا ونحن قادرون على
حل الازمه بيننا شريطه مغادره الامريكيين
بعض من اثر هذه الدعوه يتردد في العاصمه
الكوريه الجنوبيه خاصه بعدما بدا للبعض ان
واشنطن ليست شريكا موثوقا تماما عندما
يتعلق الامر بمصالحها ومثال ذلك قضيه
السيارات الكهربائيه فرغم استثماراتها
الكبيره في الولايات المتحده استثنت
واشنطن الشركه هيونداي كيا الكوريه من
الاعفاءات التي منحتها لشركات السيارات
الكهربائيه
المتحدث باسم الحزب الديمقراطي المعارض
يحذر من خطوره هذا الميل على مصالح كوريا
نفسها
العلاقات مع الصين مدمره حاليا سابقا كان
هناك حرص على التوازن حيث الامن مع
الولايات المتحده والاقتصاد مع الصين لكن
هذا تغير مع هذه الحكومه التابعه بشكل
كامل وهذا خطير
هي ايضا معادله الامن والاقتصاد والتوازن
بينهما
رهين بحسابات معقده فالصين بثقلها
الاقتصادي والعسكري ليست مجرد جار عادي
لكوريا الجنوبيه جسور التجاره تجعل منها
شريكا اقتصاديا لا غنى عنه اكثر من ذلك
فالصين بخصومتها الاستراتيجيه مع الولايات
المتحده غدت حليفا تلقائيا لكوريا
الشماليه وهي بذلك تملك بعض مفاتيح
التهدئه او التصعيد في المنطقه
ينعكس هذا الوضع القلق على السكان هنا
يتابع معظم الناس توتر الوضع صعودا او
هبوطا
لكن تم ثمن هو معنيون اكثر من غيره بكل
التفاصيل
من كوريا الشماليه فرت الى الجنوب قبل 20
عاما وتبعتها بقيه اسرتها ما زالت تعيش
على امل العوده يوما ما الى اينعت ثمره
السلام
قد تكون رغبه يائسه حقا لكن اتمنى فعلا لو
كان بامكان العوده مره واحده فقط مع
والدتي الى الشمال اتساءل اذا كان جيراننا
واصدقائنا ما زالوا على قيد الحياه
لكن اماني السلام لا تبدو قادره على
الصمود امام طبول الصراع المقروعه
يبدو اثر ذلك واضحا في هذه القريه
الحدوديه التي لا يتجاوز عدد سكانها 70
فقط
لا يسمح لغيرهم بالدخول اليها الا بتصريح
خاص
غاب السكان لكن الطبيعه لم تقبل الفراغ
هذا يونج من القله التي لم تغادر البلده
في الثالثه والتسعين من عمره يتطلع الى
التوتر بعيون التجربه وتجربه تقول ان
اشعال الحرب قد يكون سهلا لكن ان وقعت
سيكون من الصعب اطفائها
عشت تجربه الحرب ولا اتمنى ان تتكرر مره
اخرى يجب ان نحذر كوريا الشماليه اصبحت
قوه النوويه وسيكون فعلا من الحماقه اشعل
حرب لا نعرف كيف ننهيها
وتلك مخاوف يتقاسمها الجميع هنا على
الحدود ياملون الا تتحول يوما الى واقع قد
جربوا من قبل مرارته هذه اخر نقطه
يمكن تفصل هذه الاسلاك الشائكه بين
الجزئين الشمالي والجنوبي من شبه الجزيره
الكوريه حدود لا تفصل فقط بين الجارين
اللدودين ولكن ايضا بين عالمين بحسابات
جيوستراتيجيه متناقضه محمد البقالي
الجزيره من الحدود بين كوريا الجنوبيه
وكوريا الشماليه
ينضم الينا من مدينه باث البريطانيه تيمو
العلاقات الدوليه المختص بالشان الكوري
بجامعه باف مرحبا بك سيد تيمو ما الذي على
المحك بالنسبه لكوريا الجنوبيه في اي توتر
في العلاقه مع الصين
في واقع الحال
بوجود الحكومه الجديده الان اعتقد ان رئيس
يوم
والعلاقه مع الصين اصبحت اكثر توترا
الكره الجنوبيه ما زالت مرتبطه بشكل كبير
ومعتمده بشكل كبير على العلاقه الاقتصاديه
مع الصين
وحوالي الربع او ازيد من ربع مبادلات
التجاريه لهذا البلد يتم مع كوريا
الجنوبيه على الجانب الاخر
كوريا الجنوبيه مرتبطه استراتيجيا وعسكريا
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ايضا لديها علاقات
متدهوره مع
التنين الصيني وهذا يؤثر طبعا على
التوازنات
السيجيو استراتيجيه في المنطقه بشكل كبير
كيف ستوازن كوريا الجنوبيه بين العلاقتين
باعتقادك
هذا طبعا امر صعبه بالنسبه لكوريا
الجنوبيه رئيس السابق
كان اكثر حذرا فيما يتصل
يختار اي من المعسكرين
كوريا الجنوبيه هي بحاجه للصين على مستوى
الاقتصادي ورئيس السابق كان يدرك جيدا اذا
ما ابقت كوريا الجنوبيه العلاقات جيده مع
الصين
هذا سيجعلها اقل اعتمادا على المساعدات
الامريكيه لكن عندما تصبح كوريا الجنوبيه
اكثر
ادماجا في الخطط العسكريه الامريكيه فهذا
سيؤثر حتما على العلاقات مع الصين هذا
ايضا رايناه في الاونه الاخيره اذا ما لم
تكون العلاقات مع سن جيده
كوريا الجنوبيه ستحتاج اكثر للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ودعمها العسكري اذن
كوريا الجنوبيه في وضع لا تحسد عليه وهي
ينبغي الى ان تكون اكثر
قطاعه الاوامر من الطرفين الوضع صعب ومعقد
جدا بالنسبه لكوريا الجنوبيه ولا يمكن
لكوريا الجنوبيه ان تختار اي من المعسكر
لانها بحاجه لطرفين باعتقادك كيف ستمضي في
هذه الظروف
ما هو المسار المقبل الان بالنسبه لكوريا
الجنوبيه بالنظر الى كل الظروف المحيطه
بالتوتر العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
والصين وبرتباط كوريا الجنوبيه عسكريا مع
الولايات المتحده
الى حد ما
التوجه الراهن الذي تاخذه كوريا الجنوبيه
الذي هو الاقتراب على الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا
يصنع نوع من الاعتماد طبعا
الاستراتيجيه على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
واذا ما شئنا حد المشاكل او التحديات في
المرحله مرتبطه
بمساله الردعه النووي كوريا الجنوبيه
تحاول ان
يحتوي التوتر الموجود مع جارتها وهي تحاول
ان تكون نوع من الدرع الواقي من الهجمات
الدوليه المختصبه بالشان الكوري في جامعه
باث كنت ضيفنا من مدينه باس البريطانيه
بهذا مشاهدينا ننهي جوله الحصاد هذه
الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم وتصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]